- [Mark] All right. Little mama.
- Yes.
Welcome back.
So you were here a few weeks ago,
a couple of weeks ago,
with your pimp master, Jay.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And it's nice to have you back.
I think this might be
an opportunity to maybe
talk more freely about your situation.
Are you still with him?
- No.
- [Mark] So you guys parted ways?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And what can you tell
me about that relationship?
Have you had other pimps before?
- No.
With Jeffrey,
it was more like,
a relationship.
It wasn't, you know,
about him being a pimp
or anything like that.
- [Mark] But like the
money you would make,
you would give to him to handle?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But as far as you guys,
before I say...
- Here's the thing. Here's the thing.
Okay.
You know, we would play
around and stuff like that.
I would call him a 7011 pimp.
And, you know, I had to...
I did that because
we basically
met as...
Met as
as being homeless and stuff like that so.
- [Mark] When you say homeless,
you're actually just
living in hotel to hotel?
- Right.
- [Mark] So it's not really homeless,
It's just, you don't have one permanent.
- Right. Which is the
reasoning for my prostitution.
Like...
- [Mark] Yeah. You need to make
money just to pay the bills
and keep a roof over your head.
- Yeah. So pretty much it,
you know, it was about us
looking out for each other,
what we could do for each other,
you know, so.
I'm glad that's how I made him feel.
Because, you know, come on, like.
I mean, you know, maybe before, but
it's no...
Nothing like any real
pimping going on, you know.
My understanding of it is...
It's very hardcore.
It's hard to trust
people.
- [Mark] Yeah. I got the
impression, and maybe
I'm just imagining this,
that there might've been
like a little bit of like...
He almost felt like a
little abusive perhaps
or, you know, had the potential to get
physical or get...
Get violent?
- Yeah.
I mean we just...
We've been through our ups and downs.
Yeah. He did.
He trips.
He'll get mad.
And it's gotten to...
To the point where I may
even act the same way
with him.
So
I had to check myself
and,
you know, it's like
we're separate, you know.
I have him here, you know,
I don't mind being his friend,
maybe seeing him every now and then,
hanging out with him,
but we just can't be together
all the time or every day.
We can't do it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So tell me about your childhood.
You grew up with...
Tell me about was there any abuse
in your household as a kid?
- Well, there wasn't so much as abuse.
I will say that, you know,
I remember as a small child
you know, my mother and father.
I mean, you know
I could hear it.
They would throw parties, you know?
So
what was hurtful to me
and my childhood was them splitting up.
I'm, you know...
I was, you know...
It was at a very early age for me.
So I had to move around.
I had to live with mom.
I had to live with dad.
I had to live with grandmother,
you know, so.
- [Mark] But did you
feel loved as a child?
- Mmh hmm.
- [Mark] You did?
- Yeah.
I went through some motions,
but...
As I'm going through now, you know,
it's like, I'm offense...
Everything is...
I'm offensive to everything, you know,
because I know for a fact, if...
I know when it comes to me,
me being
involved,
that if I'm trying to, like,
if I make any suggestions,
it'll come out...
Things will come out better
for whatever's going on.
- [Mark] Communication.
- Yeah.
You know, it's like you say, you know,
you're basically doing
this to help people.
- [Mark] Well, I think it
just helps people understand
how these situations come to be,
and what's going on in
certain parts of our country
just to see what that...
How did this happen?
How is this going on under our noses
and no one realized it was going on
and knew how it was happening.
Now we're cutting to learn...
Starting to learn that the broken families
and the amount of abuse, sexual, physical,
all kinds of abuse,
adds up to people that are living lives
where they're just scrambling to
survive.
And they use things like
drugs and prostitution,
sex work and all kinds of different
crime.
All kinds of things just to get by.
And it comes from all-
- [Mark] Well, Imma tell you something.
Look,
I don't...
I'm not in a category with everyone else.
This is from me to you.
I don't care what's going on
in this camera right now.
I'm communicating with you as
best,
as much as I possibly can.
Okay?
The roles people play and,
you know,
things that people do.
I'm not with that.
I don't do that.
I'm not saying that I haven't fell
into a trance of acting a certain way
or doing certain things, but
I don't bullshit.
I really don't have to.
You know.
So
whether it's through you
or the man upstairs,
I'm pretty blessed.
- [Mark] That's a great attitude.
- Pretty blessed.
I'm like I am now because I'm going...
I don't know.
It's my fault...
You know, I put myself in this position.
I could've...
I should have been smarter.
I should have made other decisions.
Okay?
You know,
but I just didn't.
- [Mark] But what do you wish
you had done differently?
Earlier.
- I mean, I just wish that I would have,
you know,
not...
I just wish...
Okay, well,
it's not so much as earlier.
It's like
my life now.
I just wished that I
wouldn't involve myself
in to this lifestyle
so much anymore.
You know, I really wish I
would have made some decisions
to do other things and go elsewhere.
- [Mark] Did you finish high school?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You did?
And do you have children?
- Yes, I do.
- [Mark] How many kids do you have?
- Three.
- [Mark] Three.
And you raised them?
- I have a 25 year old son
and I have two and one
year old granddaughters.
So those are my three children.
- [Mark] Are you raising the young ones?
- Hopefully.
Hopefully.
That's
That's what...
I don't...
It's like, I don't know,
you know, what's in me to
just look past everything else
but I really want to get to that point.
I have to be Santa Claus.
I have to be.
(sniffs)
- [Mark] When you say you
have to be Santa Claus,
you mean to...
- My kids.
- [Mark] And to yourself.
Take care of yourself the same way.
make decisions that are
good for Little Mama.
Because you can do everything
in the world for your kids
and then you still suffer and
you take the whole ship down.
- Well, here's the thing.
I'm not there now.
I'm too busy hanging out.
I'm too busy
partying.
(silence)
It's just it's...
I don't know. I messed up my life.
- [Mark] Do you think
maybe you're addicted
to the whole street life, fast money,
all the drugs and all the...
The whole lifestyle?
Pretty much everyone that gets into it
finds themselves...
They find it hard to get out.
It takes a very strong mind
to pull yourself out of that
and all the temptations.
(sniffs)
What would help you climb out of it?
Where do you think?
Are you are using drugs currently?
And what do you think
would help you walk away
from this life?
- It's just...
I just have to just take the initiative
to do it.
That's the bottom line.
I gotta...
I mean that it's like
I have to have that strong moment
where I just
do what I need to do
to go where I need to go,
and nothing that's going on around me
or nobody that's around me
can make me detour from it.
- [Mark] Mmh.
You need to be very determined
and focused and not let
your friends and your...
All the temptations get the best of you.
And you just walk away from it,
turn your back on
everybody and everything,
and just go your own way.
- Do what I gotta do.
- [Mark] Do what you gotta do.
And it's gonna...
It's going to be painful
because you're gonna
start making a lot less money.
And you're gonna start not having the
fun and the excitement
and all the fast money
and all the distractions and all
the things that helped you cope.
You're gonna have to just muscle it out
and just do it on your own.
And no one's going to be there to
hold your hand while you do it.
It's going to be up to you.
No one's...
No one's there to like, "Oh yeah,
here's what you need to do.
And here's how you do."
I mean, there might be some...
Some programs that they
can help and therapy
and things like that, but it's a...
It's a very, very hard decision,
but life is full of hard decisions.
- Yes.
Yes.
- [Mark] But for your kids,
do you have a reason
to do it for yourself,
especially?
- I mean, I just, you know,
hoping that I'm able to
do it and it goes, okay?
You know?
Yeah.
- [Mark] The life you're living right now,
if you look down 10, 15,
20 years down the road,
it's not going to be okay.
- Right. Right.
- [Mark] You can see that, right?
- Yes.
- [Mark] So any
alternative might be better
than the one you've got going right now.
And
certainly the drugs and the
lifestyle and the danger
of what you do is
gonna catch up with you at some point.
(indistinct background noise)
- Uhmm...
- [Mark] Life is tough.
Life is hard.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] There is no easy way out.
Not that I've ever seen.
- Well...
Hey, I'm just like, whatever.
It ain't nothing I
haven't been through yet.
Yeah.
- [Mark] But I suspect
that you're a strong person
and you can do whatever you need to do.
You just need to put your mind to it
and not give into...
into weakness.
- Did you ask me something?
- No. All I'm saying
is you just need to be
determined to do the right
things and not give into-
- Oh. It's...
You know what?
I don't have any encouragement
but the determination
is there.
You know, I mean,
maybe not,
maybe I should, maybe that came out wrong
but it should be the opposite.
I can't...
I know that I can't keep doing this.
- [Mark] You can't.
I know that for a fact.
So I know if nothing changed it.
I mean, I don't even know if I get...
if I stop and get myself
together, you know,
or try to get myself together.
I don't even know
if it's gonna stop then,
you know what I mean?
So I know
it's not going to stop.
I can't do it.
I can't do this.
Can't do it.
Sorry.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Sorry.
- [Mark] All right.
Little Mama, thank you so
much for coming in again
and good luck with whatever
you end up deciding to do,
but it sounds like you're open
to doing something that might help you.
Help you and your kids.
- Yes.
- [Mark] That'd be great.
And maybe I'll talk to
you again when you do.
That'd be great.
I'd love to have you back.
- Okay.
So...
- [Mark] Cool.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
Thanks.